estas discrepancias con el grupo del g7
eeuu insiste en que va a cumplir con el
retiro el 31 de agosto que intenta
demostrar eeuu con este desastre que ya
ha sido calificado así por parte de la
comunidad internacional en torno al
retiro de las tropas
internacionales
bueno otra vez
obviamente la decisión del presidente de
retirar las tropas de eeuu en una manera
muy prematura obviamente nos ha traído a
esta situación pero bueno esta es la
realidad
ya tenemos que enfrentar la situación y
la primera prioridad era evacuar a los
ciudadanos de eeuu del reino unido- de
la coalición y también esos afganos que
han trabajado para nosotros que han
trabajado en nuestras embajadas por
nuestras fuerzas armadas que tenemos una
obligación sagrada de sacarlos ha habido
un esfuerzo bastante grande en el
aeropuerto de kabul se ha sacado 77 mil
personas hasta ahora y el proceso va a
seguir en un nivel muy muy grande en los
próximos días pero como usted sabe el
debate era así dejar la fecha del 31 que
había establecido presidente o moverlo
para atrás la preferencia del presidente
va en todavía es mantenerse hasta el 31
de agosto y yo creo que eso va a dejar
molestia en algunos de los otros
miembros del g7 pero en el final eeuu
tiene la preponderancia de
de fuerza y logística aérea y entonces
bueno es el presidente es la voz
decisiva
señor llorens qué puede pasar si eeuu no
cumple con este retiro el 31 de agosto
cómo queda su relación con el talibán
con afganistán con la comunidad
internacional y también con el grupo del
g7 que ellos también estaban pidiendo
una prórroga en cuanto a la fecha pero
aceptaron las condiciones de eeuu porque
eeuu garantizó que el 31 podía cumplirse
el retiro
si es una buena pregunta santiago creo
que cómo está la situación ahora yo creo
que el presidente lo que dijo es nos
vamos el 31 de agosto pero este él está
pidiendo una colaboración plena de parte
de las autoridades talibanes para
permitir a estos ciudadanos de nuestros
países y también nuestros empleados
afganos que puedan llegar en una forma
fácil
al aeropuerto como usted sabe ha habido
todo tipo de bloqueos y ahí y la
situación se ha vuelto muy complicada
entonces el presidente tiene un margen
en la que ha pedido al pentágono que le
dé un plan de contingencia en caso de
que realmente no suelen trabajar en una
forma eficaz y entonces él pudiera tomar
una decisión en conjunto con los aliados
para mover la fecha un poco para atrás
pero yo creo que obviamente como como
usted dice la preferencia de él es sacar
y terminar la operación el 31 de agosto
señor yo eres
cada día que pasa a partir del momento
que está 2-1 empezó a retirar las tropas
y de que el talibán comenzó a capturar
más y más ciudades hasta capturar kabul
son mayor los señalamientos que caen
sobre el presidente joe biden cada día
son más los sectores políticos que lo
critican incluso sus aliados
internacionales lo han criticado que
costo tendrá esto para el presidente
otra vez santiago esto fue una decisión
un error estratégico
de
con resultados catastróficos el
resultado una tragedia humanitaria para
el pueblo afgano
ha caído ha colapsado un gobierno pro
eeuu pro éste que había luchado contra
el terrorismo
es crea espacio no gobernado en
afganistán que pudiera ser utilizado por
ai se escapa por al caer a otros grupos
terroristas que se pudieron reconstituir
en un futuro que también tiene
implicaciones geopolíticas es respecto a
por ejemplo china y rúsia así que si es
un muy negativo ha sido criticado por
todo el mundo y también aquí dentro de
eeuu y no sólo dentro del partido
republicano pero también en el propio
partido del presidente